the jurogan experience joe marinelli was
my home
i was 12 years that i still to this day
i know i can
feel that place it was my home those
animals were my family it just was
it's you know it's in life when you take
for granted when something is taken from
you that you otherwise
have you know when i left that place
those animals are still on my mind they
have names they have personalities they
have
history with me and these are some
really powerful
uh relationships that i had with the
animals but
you introduced the likes of smooshy
suddenly my walrus and now i become a
freaking mother to her i mean this is
where things get really freaking weird
well explain that to people that have
never seen it in the earlier podcast
so i'll do a quick run up in 2000 uh
i don't even remember at this point 2012
i quit marineland because the uh
the conditions were such that i i didn't
have much of a choice left
and so i did but in doing so i had to
leave a walrus that had imprinted on me
she uh she was a baby walrus that came
into captivity
from you know wild caught from russia in
fact the you saw the footage of the baby
walruses is that awful
that also it's awful where they describe
how they kill the mother to take away
the baby that footage is
it's scary [ __ ] in any event so
my having been there as long as i did
and leaving i i haven't felt like i left
i felt like there was unfinished
business there i'm not leaving my walrus
behind i'm just not
and so i'm very different i'm a
different person than what i was eight
years ago joe when i was coming on here
i was a person who was desperate with a
story to tell
eight years later people know who i am
they know what's happening there's a
film about me now
if there's ever been a time that i have
a chance at saving this walrus
it is now or never does she know she
would be 18. okay joe i got stories to
tell about what she's 18.
i got stories to tell her what's
happened to her okay
let me just give you a quick update
since the we'll explain the imprinting
okay
how that worked because you can't know
how close you are to this walrus
absolutely so because the documentary is
crazy when you see that thing glued to
you
it just won't leave your side she thinks
of me every day
it's all she thinks about this is where
this is where the tide changes for me
with captivity because
i am now witness to the trauma of what's
become of an animal that's been
separated from its mother because
i know it so explain to people who don't
understand what that means like what
what happens with an animal
when it imprints happy too so uh herd
animals such as walruses that are
otherwise in
groups of uh of thousands when their
calves are born
they need to imprint on the mother so
what happens is
everything about them every attribution
whether it be the their smell
uh what they look like the sound of
their voice everything tattoos on that
animal's brains that their that baby is
able to identify that mother within
thousands
it's a scientific process that happens
at birth when smooshy came to us at two
years of age
we were doing a a procedure on another
walrus and it caused her
you know she was in a heightened state
of emotional whatnot she was going she
was
climbing all the other trainers who's
been a problem so i
i sought to pull her away from that
situation all i did was put my hands in
front of her face and she opened her
nostrils big
and i knew in that moment something had
happened because now she was following
me everywhere
and i couldn't have attributed that to
anything that i'd ever done in all of my
experiences so just the act of getting
close to her and putting your hands on
her face
i believe it was during that traumatic
whatever happened her brain circuitry
opened
and she realized that you're the one who
takes care of her i became her mom
and so days go by and you know i'm going
back there she's barking for me and i
opened the gate she's following me and
you know she wasn't
healthy when we got her so now spending
my eight hour to 12 hour shifts
actually just sleeping and smooshy's
laying on you see the footage in the
documentary she's just laying beside me
she would only eat from me
it became this crazy thing and that's
what became i mean
and that's when that's when the that's
when the world started to change for me
i
don't have children joe i don't i never
did that i mean frank that
it's not an opportunity that would have
been allotted to a person like me trying
to fight multi-million dollar lawsuits
and everything else i had to put a lot
of things on hold in life generally
my life is on hold in a lot of freaking
ways because of of
of what marineland has done i mean you
see they're sending the police to my
house all the time i mean over tweets
and [ __ ] like
what did they send the police to your
house over tweets like what
what do the police say when they show up
well these days
they leave with [ __ ] marineland stickers
they kind of love getting that call but
i don't think they want to be there they
don't really want to be there but why do
they have to show up like what are the
tweets what are you saying
because twitter will ban you if you
threaten people so you're not
threatening anybody
the tweet that i sent that sent well one
of them
was life is short steal a walrus and
they sent the police to my house because
i tweeted life is short
steal a walrus i tweeted it i took a
shower
i came back out i saw the tweet that
exploded so that's that's gonna
get some attention and the next day the
cops pull up and i said you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me so i i light up the
camera the video of course you got the
video in the film it's at the very end
of the film you see it but
here's what's become on june
1st a former employer marineland
who had been fired inexplicably she she
herself
couldn't quite understand although he
sort of figured it out over some time
she came to me and she said she had
things to tell me about smooshy
and the one thing she said that struck
me she said she was pregnant i said
that's an impossibility
17 year old walruses a it would be
really
grossly irresponsible to allow for that
to happen two
what's their lifespan well in a while
they may go 30-35 years at marineland
they don't last eight to ten
smooshy is the last one alive but what
marineland did
is they negotiated a deal to have her
transferred out
on my birthday this sounds crazy but i
have the documentation i maybe shouldn't
admit that but i do
they had plans to ship her out on march
21 my birthday
it failed it failed because of kovit
they tried two days later i got a tweet
from the cfi
from an anonymous tweet from someone
saying your friends at the cfia
stopped an export to germany to a
facility i believe and i don't want to
absolutely attribute it to it but i
believe it's the tier park zoo
in hamburg germany they you know i've
done some research
they breed walruses they know how to do
it this girl says to me
i think like they were treating smushy
like she's pregnant it's an
impossibility
there wasn't a male walrus alive in the
in the gestation period of a wall
of a walruses pregnancy in fact the math
is such that the last male died
at the same time as he would otherwise
be getting smooshy pregnant at marine
life
at marine land now i worked there 12
years and at the time we had like
a lot of walruses they never
successfully
were successfully bred in fact walrus
breeding is
a very difficult thing in captivity you
need a range of very specific things you
need uh certain
uv lighting you need some pressure you
need a number of things it's it's a it's
a rare thing and it's quite celebrated
when it happens in captivity
i didn't believe her i wouldn't believe
her but she kept telling me of things
that these that she kept telling me that
there were veterinarians from germany
that were there and that they were
manipulating her
and it happened over some time and they
were monitoring her
now when i put two and two together okay
we've got an export to to
germany that's supposed to happen in
march cancelled on account covet
we've got uh we've got a girl telling me
now that there's german veterinarians
that are manipulating smooshy i tweeted
i have something to the effect i'm
paraphrasing but sometimes the effect of
you know i have
on good uh reason to believe that
smooshy's been uh inseminated like she's
been made pregnant
and uh june 3rd marineland tweeted that
smooshy had given birth to a calf
there's not been a picture of smooshy
since over a year ago
on account of kovid smooshy was never
taken out the
the park operated but you know obviously
there was not a lot of numbers but
they because of the rules of bill s 203
which we had passed in canada which bans
the the captive
of uh of wells dolphins and the purposes
it also uh limits their
performance they they're not actually
allowed to perform for entertainment no
more uh much of the advertising
is not allowed and what not so
when i read marineland's press release
of what they
you know of smooshy's calf's birth which
i aptly named
june which was the the month she was
born and is also the name of the
marinelands veterinarian
they said they were monitoring smooshy
carefully and that
you know these this that giving birth is
a risky thing
we've not seen a picture of her since
there's not been an iota of an update in
fact
i started to at one point i tweeted it's
time for me
to accept that smooshy's probably dead
it had been months
and whereas marineland used to respond
to my tweets with an update of smooshy
there was nothing
there was nothing now i knew that there
was efforts to have her shipped out and
whatnot
so what happened was social media
started getting flooded marineland
social media people started saying where
the [ __ ] is smooshy
not only supporters of mine people that
support marineland marineland's response
and this is a this was a national
article in all of canada
they completely ignored everything all
media requests
my lawyers requests we just want to know
where smooshy is we want to know if
she's still alive
they blocked everybody they're blocking
fans they're blocking everybody people
started to call marineland's lawyer
marineland's lawyer who has attributed
himself as marineland spokesperson in
public
was a pallbearer at john holder's death
was now telling people if you want
answers about marineland call marineland
he is marineland he's the one that does
the answers
where the [ __ ] is smooshy that's where
i'm at today
i don't know with absolute certainty
that she's alive but i should mention
that i have been told by a lot of people
that she is
i have reason to believe that she is i
don't absolutely know
like how does someone know that who is
someone who works there so because the
people that work there so so what i
should mention is that girl who
had told me this information that got
fired inexplicably it turned out because
she was like a junior trainer
she was inadvertently in a meeting where
they had gone over the details of the
german vets coming in and whatnot and
one of the trainers were actually trying
to stop marineland's lawyer from
revealing too much because that girl
shouldn't have been there
and a week later she was fired she
doesn't understand what the hell
happened
i don't know that that's exactly the
story because this is what she says to
me imagine former employees come to me
with stories and i
typically tell people if you're a former
employee you know you're not really good
to me anymore i mean if you didn't have
if you didn't have the gumption to do
something while you're an employee don't
come to me now because i don't know that
you haven't been fired because your dick
i don't know your backstory i don't know
that i'm able to trust your information
but
hers came and i did do the tweet and it
it wound up being absolutely
absolutely true catch new episodes of
the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience